[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome to day three of netflix geet
week 2022. day three baby and thanks
everybody for joining us i'm ella
pannell you may know me from the
animated series arcane and i am tiffany
smith from masters of the universe we're
halfway through the week and we have
already revealed some really cool stuff
so much stuff we've had drop-ins from
the likes of zack snyder the russo
brothers and chris hemsworth and chris
hemsworth come today
i think he's here he's asking for you in
the back
we have also gotten first look at shows
like the sandman and 1899.
honestly there were too many great
moments to name all of them it's true
and we're not even close to done yet you
guys we've got so much more stuff coming
today we're gonna just like mix it up a
little bit because today on geek week we
are featuring some of netflix's hottest
upcoming animated titles so
let's jump right into it
okay tiffany
we're starting with a big announcement
and it's one that i'm gonna let you set
up for us oh i'm so excited thank you
ella this is a title that is near and
dear to my heart so let's take a look
[Music]
oh my god okay
i was like masters of the universe
revelation no
it's now called masters of the universe
revolution
that's right we are returning to eternia
with an all-new follow-up mini-series
masters of the universe revolution i am
so excited that i got to be the one to
reveal this this sequel to masters of
the universe revelation picks up right
where the previous animated series left
off it's true we ended in a really cool
spot so i'm very excited to see where we
go in the new episodes and see who maybe
comes in to join us in eternia i don't
know okay always great people coming in
expect to see more he-man and more
skeletor in a conflict like you've never
seen before and of course all your other
favorites like i mean my favorite on
i want to watch this i am so pumped and
honestly like doing the first season was
so wonderful was so much fun and i'm so
excited to see where they're going to
take andra in the new mini series i have
always wanted to know what is mark
hamill like
um so here's the crazy thing we shot
during the pandemic so i didn't get to
be in the same room with anybody so it
was all voice over did you do any
recording like with other people when
you do it yeah it's always in your booth
on your own did you do any in your
cupboard or in your box i did so i made
half of my closet into a point
so yes i did that mm-hmm and it's like
you get to work with these people but
not where it's like i remember the
episodes coming out with mark hamill and
i'm a huge star wars fan so i was like i
get scenes with mark hamill but i've
never actually talked to him
to do it because you'll claim to fame
you can still tell everyone it's true
it's true but i love it because you get
to be a part of a project where you geek
out
yourself on a project that you're
working on yeah which is awesome that's
great be sure to continue following
netflix geek for all the latest
information on all things masters of the
universe revolution as you know today is
all about animation so let's dive into a
title that we know the fans have been
begging for wonder storms the dragon
prince
they will raid fire upon us
the only way to stop this is to look
evil in the face and say
no
more
[Music]
we have a sneak peek at season four the
start of the next phase of the saga
mystery of eravos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
okay so the teaser we got a ton of
action yes dragons fighting war
craziness
and that one i was like what is
happening when arevos's huge arm comes
in yeah yeah yeah that confused me that
confused me too i thought that there
were dolls and we're selling dolls i
don't know i want some of those
i want these selling and these
yeah i know do i want to be an elf yes
yes i do yes i feel like whenever i
watch these kinds of shows i'm like i
just want to be that in real life yeah
you know that's the thing about
animation right yes yeah exactly so much
freedom they do so much with like the
different elements in that one having
different powers based off elements if
you could pick an element to have power
based off of what would it be
like the last airbender i
would i would want air i would want to
fly
yeah and blow really hard at people
that's all they really want to do okay
well following the epic season 3
conclusion of the dragon prince there
are so many big questions remaining
but none are bigger than the question of
who is the star judge elf aravos and
what does he want what does he want and
what is the price the heroes human and
elf alike will have to pay to stop him
it better not be a baby dragon
huge changes are coming and the stakes
for our heroes have never been higher if
you need a refresher on all things the
dragon prince seasons one through three
are now streaming on netflix
now speaking of the stakes never being
higher for our heroes i might know a
little something about that
yeah because you're the one who's
raising the stakes
you are it's me
of course you do the world of league of
legends came to life an incredible
series from riot games and fortisch
productions and honestly i'm still
recovering from that jaw-dropping
cliffhanger of the finale but i'm very
excited to see where it's going to go in
the next season me too me too i know
where it goes but so can you for the
sake
you know i just like i love it i wish i
want to
i wish i could but
i can't tell you
i tried guys i really tried
the team at ortiz is working hard right
now on the second season of arcane and i
cannot wait to find out more about the
absolute carnage jinx will surely bring
to pilt over and zone
well to tide you over our friends at
riot made a behind the scenes series to
take us inside the making of arcane and
we have a sneak peek right now let's
take a
we're just look of talking you know like
man like how fun it would be to make
something that's a bit bigger you know
and the animation space and the story
space
and to kind of embrace all these
different strengths that the team had
developed over the years animation music
every child
sounds dumb
building characters stories and just go
deep on it
we had this amazing amazing partner in
fortish this animation studio in paris
[Music]
we work with them on the jinx music
video
on the imagine dragons music video for
warriors
they just always have this like this x
factor of like these beautiful visuals
it's super artistic and everything it
just kind of always clicked you know
i
always thought
that
if there's any superpower that we had in
the beginning to make arcane a thing it
was
whether or not we could really
unleash the potential of fortish
wow
that's crazy i don't even know how like
any of that stuff it's really cool to to
see that for the first time this is my
first time seeing that too it is
so cool and i have to say like one of
the things i love the most about the
show is they trust the audience to
figure things out everything doesn't get
explained to you from the very beginning
it's like you go along and you kind of
pick up pieces along the way yeah and
the music
the music is crazy good it's bonkers
it's really cool yeah it's really cool
thanks
glad you liked it i liked it a lot i
liked a lot so that's the season one
finale do you want to know what happens
next
do you i do
i do
um okay so since you can't give us any
spoilers could you tell us do you have a
favorite line as jinx oh
um
damn i do
but i can't remember i'm the worst for
spoilers like the worst you're like
season two i can't remember if it's
season one or season two because we've
we've shot a lot of season two so i do
have a favorite line but i'm not gonna
say it because i don't want to get fired
i like my job everything about her is so
bad that's one of the things i like
about her she's funny like she has
obviously that like vulnerable side but
like she's psycho funny i like it yeah
yes she is
she really really is arcane has really
become a phenomenon and there are so
many fans of the show of league of
legends obviously have you seen any of
the tick tocks or cosplays or anything i
don't have tick tocks i haven't seen
those but i've seen the cosplays and
they are so crazy good i don't like i
don't understand how people do it i
actually i want to do a cosplay of jenks
so bad
someone make the cosplay for her someone
help me
um do you have anything else that you
want to share with the fans today um
like i said season two is in the works
right now so we don't have anything new
to share but i do have one treat that
fans have been asking for okay demanding
ever since arcane launched
oh yeah
oh yeah that is right profile icons okay
so
who what what profile icon do you pick
oh come on it's got to be jinx it's
gotta be it's gotta be jinx okay if you
can't pick drinks though who would you
pick oh god um
i don't know vi looks pretty cool i
don't know actually this is a really
hard choice they all look really cool
sealcoat's like a little it's got a
little something evil and sexy going on
can i say that
weird it's a little weird i mean let's
be honest animated characters sometimes
sometimes they're very sexy or sexy who
would you pick um
my oh i thought you were asking me sexy
animated characters and i was like dream
from sandman different first major oh
really oh my god yes yes wow hoodie hit
first guys excited to see that series um
i would pick bye
yeah um she's cool i mean it would be a
toss up i think it would depend on my
mood
i might touch it up like depending on
what i'm watching it'd be like okay i
get that
maybe tomorrow's jinx we'll see well
listen you guys get to choose as well
because arcane profile icons are
available right now on netflix now you
can say jinx was here
so we got her we got her to give us a
little little tidbit
we'll get some more a little bit a
little bit
okay so arcane has one incredible
soundtrack like we talked about and so
does our next title yes let's check out
intergalactic which is going to be the
animation event of the year it's from
the mind of kid cudi and produced by
kenya barris intergalactic is an
animated adult story that follows a
young man on his journey to discover
love ah that's nice
the main character is voiced by cuddy
himself and the rest of the voice cost
is stacked and we are ever so lucky here
at geeked week to reveal that full voice
cast right now names that you are gonna
know as part of the exclusive first look
at intergalactic
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
[Music]
okay
what wow that is a crazy voice cast that
is is vanessa hudgins ty dolla there are
so many mccall macaulay called me
wow i love it i love it so it was cool i
also loved the style the animation style
was really cool i cannot wait to i feel
like it's it's not a new thing but the
music that goes along with all these
animated series is always yeah so
awesome and this geek week has been no
different every time we show a new clip
i'm like that music is awesome and i'm
like dancing well
exactly the intergalactic universe
sounds and looks beautiful
that kid cudi i really think he's got a
career ahead of him
you should tell him that i just did
because he's probably watching this
right yeah he wants to see him live
streaming he wants to see his trailer
all right on to another groundbreaking
animated series love death and robots
from david fincher and tim miller just
returned with volume three
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
the acclaimed series is known for
pushing the boundaries of animation and
the volume three short hebrew directed
by the oscar and emmy award winner
alberto mielgo is unlike anything else
we've ever seen
wow we are going to take you inside the
animation for the inside scoop on how
the love death and robots team brought
the cinematic masterpiece to the screen
using a variety of animation techniques
check it out right here only on netflix
geeked week
i think that if you want to do animation
for adults you need to be wild and you
need to be extreme hero is like a brutal
disaster
what i wanted to do first of all is a
story with no heroes no good characters
and it's just a tragedy
i wanted to talk about
the most toxic relationship that you can
imagine
i think that both characters are very
much myself like many times i go
for that thing that feels extremely
dangerous
full of red flags everywhere
it's kind of like challenging and cool
to talk about yourself especially when
one is so intimate and so private
i love animation
over anything like it's been my passion
forever that's what i always wanted to
do and being able to explore the
narrative worlds is extremely satisfying
[Applause]
the animation looks pretty rich and real
because it's actually shot with real
characters in my films we do work with
actors to actually see their emotions to
record their acting in their faces and
obviously their body mechanics
we got a choreographer sarah silken
incredible and then we have a number of
really incredible dancers they were able
to
own their body and control their body
i'm very obsessed with with animation
and human movement in general and i like
to keep working this way
the intensive work that you have to do
in order to create just 15 minutes of
animation which is nuts we were 72
people you need to create a world from
scratch you need to design it you need
to model it you need to rig it there is
a huge amount of process
i also wanted to do a homage to
nature
the sounds and the colors
in order to do that i rent a van and i
got inside of the forest and i live
basically inside of the forest for two
weeks this is something that i usually
do i like to go on location and find the
right shots when i was there i saw that
nature is so raw and so beautiful and
the colors they were just perfect
[Music]
i was very much also reinventing what a
renaissance parade of nights can look
like it was a pretty cool opportunity to
explore color and to explore how color
reflects on these armors as well
in 3d we have the advantage that we
don't need to have a body underneath we
don't need to have a man kind of like
complaining or an actor saying like oh
my god this doesn't move well
for the woman i was very much based in
all these beautiful jewelry and head
pieces from western europe russia
india and north of africa i just wanted
to create a world that is rich and
beautiful
it is like a lot of sound in nature
actually
it can be very chill and very quiet but
when you are full on inside of a forest
it's very rich in sound versus what a
deaf person might hear and i did my own
interpretation of what this can be
film is very much about listening it's
not so much about hearing
even though we have a deaf character
it's about listening uh listening in
terms of like
red flags not uh putting attention to
red flags or signals
in the case of the woman she can
actually have everything else but she
cannot have that person because you
cannot hear her
[Music]
it is true that there is a
theme
that is actually going through all my
stories which is kind of relationships
and love i am very interested on
losers more than in
heroes or in superheroes i find that a
super loser is more interesting in my
opinion for the stories that i want to
tell
[Applause]
there is still a little bit of a stigma
of what is animation at least on
mainstream
most important is to explore cinema
rather than the technique itself of the
animation i would like that we actually
break that barrier
working in this anthology love this and
robots i personally feel
really free in terms of ideas exploring
new narratives they were trying
something very radical
you can have violence you can have
thriller horror nudity anything that is
adult and that's something that i really
appreciate as a as an artist
[Music]
damn okay i know i what i love about
this show is or series
is that every single episode is
different and not just the storytelling
but the animation is different too it's
crazy yeah it's really inspiring as well
because you you just get to like i don't
watch a ton of different styles i kind
of stick to the genres i like but
getting to watch something like this you
get to see a little bit a little slice
of everything and like really make up
your mind about you know what you're
drawn to and see so many different
artists work it's really cool it's also
cool because obviously it deals with
love death and robots but you get comedy
you get action exactly you get horror
there's so many different genres that
they play with and i love getting to see
different versions of stories that
different auteurs kind of like put their
stamp on
honestly it's one of those shows where
there is truly something for everyone
okay
it's time to change gears a bit to a
show that gives new meaning to the term
adult animation
this new series from roger black and
waco oh gwen the same sick minds who
created brickleberry and paradise pd
is definitely not for kids so earmuffs
if you're watching
and with that warning we now have an
exclusive trailer for fazer let's check
it out
hold on is this going to be more like
futurama or rick and morty it's gonna be
more like shut the [ __ ] up
this is fawza
it was a peaceful planet before the evil
aliens invaded
but brenzo protected his people from the
aliens and their diabolical leader
buzzer
i'm stuck to the floor hell
then wenzel married queen flemmi totally
for love not just to gain power even
though she's a slightly older woman oh
yes come on twerk them tits you know
what mommy likes
dad what i really want is to be a
general sure i'll put a quote-unquote
team together for you
oh
yeah
welcome to the team
it's my destiny to rid this planet of
evil who's the wise ass put a manual
transmission this thing you know i can't
drive stick you [ __ ]
you guys say you think we're a jew
of course your goddamn joke i bought
that general outfit from party city you
idiot
and
i like that nasty [ __ ]
you pork this dork you better stay on
your side of the vagina that won't be a
prop i have a shockingly slender penis
what does this watch do it opens up
wormholes
but only to my mother's shower so
it's broken no
i am
someone rolled me to my dressing room
and if you roll me through gum again
i'll have your [ __ ] ass
okay i love [ __ ] like that this is my
favorite type of animation and i'm proud
of it proud of it i don't know what it
is about seeing an animated character
curse or say really inappropriate things
it's like hard to just you can't not
laugh
you can't not you can't and i feel i
related to this one i also can't drive
sticks so and i love party city so
this show was made for me it's true i'm
into it i also always look at vehicles
and stuff in anime i don't know why i'm
like he was driving on some kind of like
it looked like a land sea doo thing at
the beginning and then the giant
scorpion thing
creative yeah i'm having something to
see you guys all the stuff i would put
on my bookshelves like of figures that i
would buy
and that was the version that was safe
for us to show you guys here so i don't
know where the show's actually gonna go
well if you want to see the full
uncensored farsa trailer head over to
netflix geek on twitter
up next get ready to be spooked in space
with exception we announced the new
anime exception during last year's
geeked week and this year we're excited
to top that by revealing the first look
images exception takes place on a
dystopian earth with humanity at the
brink of extinction in the series humans
are forced to leave earth and look for a
new place to survive in the galaxy but
an advanced team of spacecrafts arrive
at a planet that is to be terraformed
and each member of the team is output by
a biological 3d printer
that's crazy why not it's so cool
cool this is kind of interesting it
looks a little like a cane
it does with the hextech it really yeah
and what is at the center of that i is
it a map so many questions is it a power
source
i don't know good cat eye
who does your makeup have that cat eye
that's true a 3d bio printer that hey
you know
the hat yep i feel like that's really
cool i really like her would shop at the
same stores yes yeah yeah she's actually
jinx's cousin um
they've never met but they come from the
same family
oh this is really really cool i like
these images a lot i love when people do
like what would a futuristic spaceship
look like especially when hearing that
they're doing the
bio 3d printing and it's like it almost
looks like a fish in the ocean but it's
in space and so yeah that's like
bio-printed spaceship yeah
huh
yeah i wanna
i wanna get close
we both
i have so many questions
is that like a star that's about to
explode behind her what's happening big
window
there's a lot going on there's a lot
going on i like i feel like i have no
idea where that show is gonna go a lot
of mystery yeah a lot of questions or
what's gonna happen to all these crazy
cool interesting looking characters
who are they i don't know i guess we'll
have to tune in later this year to find
out
all right you guys well don't fly off in
your 3d printed bio spaceships just yet
because we've got another great new
sci-fi anime series for you moonrise in
moonrise we follow the life of jack as
he confronts various hardships in the
vast world of outer space
it's brought to us by the anime
visionaries at wit studio who are
responsible for hit shows like bubble
vampire in the garden and attack on
titan this exciting new anime is penned
by the critically acclaimed novelist and
screenwriter toh ubukata make sure to
keep an eye out for moonrise you know
tiff
can i call you tiff yes you can
anime is the most heavenly art form i
can think of
you know what elle
can i call you that no
it's a great way to i thought we were i
thought we
were job
sorry
fine
then jinx coming out it's true it's true
it's a great way to introduce the seven
deadly sins though no i didn't say it
was a sin i i said it was heavenly no i
know that but i was talking about the
netflix movie the seven deadly sins the
grudge of edinburgh oh well in that case
we have a look at the characters in the
latest installments of the seven deadly
sins saga
the seven deadly sins the grudge of
edinburgh is an upcoming two-part film
based on the newly drawn spin-off
original story by nakaba suzuki the
story will focus on tristan the son of
meliotis who was the main character of
seven deadly sins series part one is
coming to netflix this december in
addition to the new series we also have
the exciting news that one of your new
favorites will be back for part two
inside job
from creator shion takeuchi inside job
is of course about the employees of
cognito inc where conspiracies aren't
just the theories they're a full-time
grind
this series is a peak inside the actual
deep state as one woman reagan ridley
manages the chaotic office of lovable
[ __ ] secretly controlling the world
we've got a clip from the opening of the
newest episode check it out
and here is the white house where
oh god it's that drunk again avert your
eyes kids hey kids everything they teach
you in school is a lie the deep state is
controlled by my [ __ ] father
chemtrails trap you in the 80s minions
are real i have seen one i have touched
one with my own hands
oh my gosh it's a bomb
wait are those two
hey
plurals
so
are you you good i know it's your first
day back since your dad took over and
all of course i'm okay we'll make you
think that i'm not okay oh god
well you did get a [ __ ] stamp that says
mommy likey drinky on it whoa when did i
get that
life is just dreams turning to entropy
you little shits
she doesn't mean that children i do mean
it dreams die santa is fake but student
dead is real
you had to learn sometime braden
listen to me brett my dad is an amoral
sociopath having him in charge will
literally destroy the world
yeah he's installed a lot of security
cameras in the women's bathrooms rand
ridley is a dick
[ __ ] talking detected
this is nauseating me bruh and for
breakfast i had something called a bud
light limerita the refreshing bud light
mist with a tropical lime twist
we have to do something don't worry i
mean ran can't make things that
different
listen up peons everything's gonna be
different around here i've carefully
reviewed this year's agenda from the
robes and i don't give a [ __ ]
why are we taking orders from mysterious
world [ __ ] anyway we don't even know
who they are
from now on we do what i say cognito is
gonna reclaim its glory days
and then cognito's gonna reclaim its
ex-wife and its daughter and its
original beautiful hairline
this is going to be the most globally
damaging midlife crisis since elon musk
hey get to the war room you two
oh my god his kimono's open oh i can't i
cannot see that don't barf because then
i'm in the back
[Music]
i feel like those last couple of seconds
like implanted something in my brain
i'm freaking out i think this might be
my new favorite show how have i never
seen this
wow so many good lines yeah i want to
get printed on t-shirts i thought you're
gonna say you want to get printed like
the [ __ ] stamp title i want to get
mommy likey drinky if that
i want that on a sweatshirt and one on
the front mommy likey drinky and on the
back santa's fake but student debt is
real
genius i love you genius yep you know
we're just we're just making ideas
creating stuff
i
really enjoyed that okay you heard it
here first on geek tweet we're getting a
second season of inside job
yes and we are so glad that they're back
part two of inside job drops later this
year if you're a fan of inside job and
animation check out netflix geek on tik
tok you're sure to have a laugh okay now
it's time to chat anime mm-hmm up next
we have a new series coming from japan
uncle from another world
can't wait this series is about a young
man's uncle who wakes from a 17-year
coma now with magical powers and a love
for video games
he looks pretty normal is this is this
the
guy who wakes up 17 years later i don't
know because these are exclusive never
seen before images so i'm seeing these
at the same time that you are i like his
glasses 17 years that is that's freaking
crazy and it's a lot to catch someone up
on i'd start with netflix
so there's this streaming service it's
pretty crazy to wrap your head around um
oh first of all there's tvs and there's
internet i mean right really really
i love it and it's so exciting to see an
isak anime in the netflix lineup uncle
from another world is coming to netflix
this july
okay geek tweak it's a bit of an
understatement when i say
this next series is
huge
i know what you're setting up and i have
to say
it is
gigantic kong is back and bader than
ever in the animated series kong skull
island based on the film by george and
vote roberts it's major news of any
animation studio to bring legendary's
monsterverse to hand-drawn life it is
the incredible team at powerhouse
animation
here is an exclusive first look image of
this highly anticipated new animated
series
what are we seeing okay two people just
hanging out on what looks like maybe a
beach some physical contact we like
affection
slow slow zoom out
gigantic
what print
okay i mean it's bit you've got a mids
it's it is big it is very big i can't
wait to see the kong that made that
footprint
when a group of good-hearted explorers
fish a drowning girl out of the ocean
they have no idea that they've found
themselves on a collision course with
strange beasts terrifying titans and the
most mysterious island the world has
ever known the larger-than-life kong
updates
head over to twitter and check out
netflix geeked we are almost at the end
of our time with you but we have two
massive announcements still to go like
this next series which is an exclusive
title announcement from geeked week
we could set up what you're about to
learn but why would we when we could get
the definitive master of horror in manga
junji ito to do it for us take it away
sir
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was so cool yeah it blows my mind
the things that people create and write
and i know that i will be watching and i
will also have nightmares after watching
that
probably you have to wait a whole year
for this but i am very excited i'll get
prepared by then junjie ito's maniac a
brand new anime series is coming to
netflix soon
that is so badass it's so scary i feel
like i'm gonna need to get my blankets
ready to come yeah this seems to be a
theme with you i'm noticing i'm a
chicken but i like watching it like we
should put it together we could both
have pillows up in front hold cover your
eyes like this
yeah a little bit of that a little bit
of blanket a little bit everything it'll
be fun well his work has transcended
borders to both capture the imagination
and frighten audiences everywhere i mean
we're scared already
thank you junji idosan for taking the
time to record that geeked week sneak
peek now if you love horror anime or
both make sure you check out junji ito's
maniac and if you love anime in general
specifically netflix anime please head
over to our twitter and hit follow on
netflix anime for more information on
the animation you know and love yeah
okay up next and this is our grand
finale a series that fans have been
dying to learn more about ever since it
was first announced two years ago
hot cocoa and marshmallows macaroni and
cheese peanut butter and jelly things
that just they just go perfectly
together right well that is just like
the incredible teams at cd projekt red
and studio trigger cdpr are the creators
of iconic games like the witcher 3 and
of course cyberpunk 2077. and trigger is
the studio behind groundbreaking anime
such as kill la kill and little witch
academia they both have been working
very hard on the new anime series
cyberpunk edgerunners which expands the
world of night city in exciting and
surprising new ways
netflix anime sat down with the teams
behind cyberpunk edge runners cdpr in
poland and studio trigger in japan to
give us an inside look at the making of
this exciting new project but we've been
hearing about cyberpunk edgerunners for
years
i don't know about you but i'm ready to
see something
well then
let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
what did i just see
okay was it worth the wait tiffany i
love that it was like a slow burn at the
beginning where it's like oh yeah slowly
getting into it then all of a sudden it
just amped up i stamped up the images
and i was like what am i saying exactly
exactly it was well worth and the music
made me want to do things fast yeah made
me want to be fast
anime as an art form in general has had
a tremendous influence on both cyberpunk
as a genre and cyberpunk 2077 as a video
game
cyberpunk edgerunners is an homage to
but also a fresh look at anime and video
game-based shows don't go anywhere
because netflix anime sat down with the
teams behind cyberpunk to give us an
inside look at the making of this
exciting new project
okay then we should probably go because
i really want to watch that video but
before we go i want to say a huge thank
you for hanging out with us i'm tiffany
smith i'm ella pannell let's dance it
out all right
[Music]
want to stay in the know about your
favorite netflix shows and films you'll
find news videos interviews and more on
to boom the official netflix site to
help find and fuel your fandom stranger
things the grey man the umbrella academy
and more make peak week last all year on
netflix.com
[Music]
the game was very realistic very serious
and still
the anime has realistic story but
very bombastic visuals and that's i
think one of the most original mixes you
you can see it fulfills a quite
different role than a video game because
in the video game it's all about
the immersion and the power fantasy of
being in night city where for the show
we explore
things and topics that were not possible
in that specific experience of a video
game as for who edge runner is
for me it was always a pirate a rebel
pirate that wants to fight with with the
system yeah somebody that tries to uh
win his personal freedom because in this
world it's pretty obvious that nobody is
going to change the world fundamentally
but what cyberpunks are fighting for is
to carve out a very small piece of the
world around them where they can be
themselves and have the freedom for
their
own actions and for the loved ones that
they have
[Music]
in our game we have this kind of
progression prepared for the player and
we basically focus mostly on the
weaponized cyborg right some that
enhance your power and your abilities
you in the game you want to become a
superhuman on the anime on the other
hand we can explore more a bit this
social aspect of cyber world like focus
on something that you know was not super
important in the developments through in
the game for the player but it is
important for the regular people living
in the in the city yeah i think that the
game is all about immersion
and
the anime is more concerned about being
believable
as a world of cyberpunk
what i love in the show is that trigger
literally took our cyberpunk city and
everything that we designed really
seriously and they simply elevated
everything in a very stylized manner you
see cyberware there's going to be way
more you see gore way more fun more
beautiful designs city
more trigger
loved cyberpunk 2077 they loved playing
the cyberpunk i remember the moment that
they came to us and said we love hollow
fish and you will see it in the anime
they look exactly like the the one we
have in the game and it was super cool
that trigger was falling in love with
some elements of the game literally
every single frame is a painting chasing
moon scene activation of santa distant
the ghost scenes like each moment is
important and each moment is made out of
hundreds of frames of paintings actually
yeah the tones are similar but there are
much more colors much more flare much
more everything so it's a game elevated
to
to something amazing every single
painting has some experience that you'll
be able to discover and enjoy and that
makes me
watch more yeah i'd like to experience
this journey
we have our pair of protagonists that's
lucy and david where david is a kid that
uh comes from a rather rough
neighborhood and he just wants to be
with his mom and wants to be accepted by
the environment that he is in but
the city you know throws huge curveballs
to him and from that point we start the
story lucy is uh
is a netrunner and we don't know much
about her in the beginning because she
is very introvert she doesn't like to
talk about herself that combination of
somebody that wants to be
just happy and with the people that he
loves and protagonists like lucy where
there is a quite big thing looming over
her from her past but also she's also
fighting for her freedom and for the
choice of being loved and fighting for
the people that she cares about but also
a story about
finding the right people in your lives
that matter to you and that you want to
sacrifice yourself for
the body modification or the cyberware
how we call it is the absolute fundament
of cyberpunk it's is the the reason of
all things in cyberpunk world right in
this world uh everybody has cyber and uh
the cyberware is was supposed to be the
biggest achievement of mankind while it
become its biggest curse curse basically
right so this technology has brought
bring the society into this endless
spiral of
abuse and violence and i think what's
interesting to explore both in the game
but also in the anime is that this
really gives you the opportunity to
showcase how real people
live in this world with
the added benefit of what happens if you
have to actually chop your arm off to be
able to work in a factory because that's
necessary for you to do that and what
does it cost you on the human level but
also how does it
change your stance within the society
and what we explore in cyberpunk edge
runners in that specific sense is that
david attains a very
cool cyberware at the start of the
series but it's a shortcut
and in the city where always the bill is
due how does it actually happen and we
want to kind of tag along for the ride
to see how far can david push before
something inevitable happens
foreign
the tension is already here right the
almost mexican standoff that was in the
game and
you have a feeling that the scene from
the game was so iconic that they repeat
the same stuff but i don't think it's
it's a copy and we will see that in the
moment in a moment uh that it's a it's a
dialogue with the game absolutely these
guys are like showing off yeah this is
like the style over substance which is a
pretty important when it comes and they
they they
live with the sentence you know what i
mean that it's super important like
they're showing off they modify their
body
so heavily that they are on the edge
of being a human
[Applause]
one of the most important cyberwin the
whole anime sunday vistan it's i would
say that it's something like a bullet
time right yeah yeah that he slows down
time he's maybe not he slows down time
but but he's faster than that
than everybody so they don't even see
what he's doing and that's why he saves
back exactly it's their shot yeah like
there's the spine shirt yeah here it
injects this adrenaline shot and the sun
the vista is on exactly like every to
the every single muscle yeah it just you
as faster stronger you see more things
and you can you can you can simply you
know check your position check your spot
heat first and build advantage
that's that's one of the best scene i
love it so much that lucy comes with the
nanowire and cuts of
maelstrom's
arms and hands and that's crazy and
that's super stylish and that's gory and
i
i love it i could i could watch it
forever and when he when she's literally
chopping his hands
like you know like a salami
this is exactly the fantasy i wanted to
achieve with nanoblades in the game
right
he really enjoys it right
you can tell yeah and everyone is happy
he's like we did it cool
and they're next so cool about it yeah
yep when i was
playing the game i was scared when i
when i looked at maelstrom gang i was i
was terrified because they are the most
crazy gang in in night city and i feel
that the
scene in the anime is like catharsis
that you think absolutely yeah that you
can feel for the first time that oh they
are not scary if you have your gang if
you have your gang of edge runners you
can cut them you can kill them you can
turn them into the
splash
or pulp or
anything and it's so cool that it's
so connected to the game that trigger
plays with the
audience and players expectations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
want to stay in the know about your
favorite netflix shows and films you'll
find news videos interviews and more on
to boom the official netflix site to
help find and fuel your fandom stranger
things the grey man the umbrella academy
and more make peak week last all year on
netflix.com